what's not to love when it comes to
croissants flaky on the outside soft and
buttery on the inside they might just be
our favorite french pastry though easy
to enjoy croissants can be difficult to
perfect especially if you're making them
at home the process takes practice and a
lot of patience but trust us when we say
it's worth it we tested hundreds of
croissants to bring you the best classic
croissant and have you baking like a pro
so let's get into it
we're going to start by making our dough
our dough consists of eight ingredients
milk water flour
sugar
salt yeast malt and butter in a large
bowl combine the milk and water a lot of
croissant recipes call for just water
but we found that a combination of water
and whole milk creates that tender crumb
we want the added sugar from the milk
will also help us achieve that deep
copper color okay next we'll add the
flour we're using bread flour because
it's high in protein and one of the
strongest flours available it's going to
help provide the structural support for
our dough the extra protein in bread
flour makes for better volume chewier
crumb and more browning in the crust now
we'll add our sugar
salt
yeast
and malt for extra flavor the last
ingredient for our dough is unsalted
butter not all croissant recipes use
butter in the dough but we found that a
small amount of butter fat in the dough
helps during the lamination process
we'll mix this together with our hands
until the dough resembles a shaggy mass
we don't want to develop gluten here we
just want to hydrate the flour and
create a unified dough trust your
instincts here if your dough feels too
wet like this it will be more difficult
to roll out which will cause the butter
to shatter when laminating you can
always add a little bit more flour here
if your dough is too dry it'll begin to
tear during rolling and eventually bake
into something more similar to a bread
roll than a pastry unfortunately there's
really no fix for this cover the bowl
with plastic wrap or a kitchen towel and
allow the dough to rest at room
temperature until it rises to about one
and a half times its original size and
has a slightly puffy texture this will
probably take about an hour depending on
the temperature of your kitchen okay
this looks good we'll punch down the
dough and transfer it onto a piece of
plastic wrap then gently press the dough
into a rough eight inch square there we
go then we'll wrap the dough tightly and
refrigerate for at least three hours but
preferably overnight let's move on to
one of the most crucial steps of
croissants the butter block or barrage
it's really important to use a high
quality butter we recommend using
european or european style butter
because we're looking for at least 84
butter fat that's going to help give our
croissants that famous honeycomb finish
to make the butter block place a sheet
of parchment paper on a work surface
with the long side nearest to you next
we'll slice the butter into quarter inch
thick pieces and arrange the slices in a
single layer like tiles
fold the edges of the parchment paper to
encase the butter and flip the packet
over so the seam is facing down we'll
let the butter packet rest at room
temperature until it's soft but not
greasy chilled yet pliable is what most
recipes will tell you we essentially
want the butter to be a little bendy but
not break
for us it took about 30 minutes for our
butter to reach this consistency then
we'll take a rolling pin and roll it
over the packet to distribute the butter
in an even layer all the way to the
edges and corners leaving no spaces
between the tiles and there you have it
place the butter packet in the
refrigerator to chill until you're ready
to laminate alright let's laminate first
thing we need to do is lock the butter
into the dough to do this we want to
make sure that our butter and our dough
are about the same temperature and
texture simply hold the butter in one
hand and the dough in the other hand and
feel them we'll dust our work surface
very lightly with flour we will use our
butter block as the guide to how large
we roll out our dough we want to roll
out our dough to be about the same width
and about twice the height of our butter
packet once the dough is rolled out
place the packet butter side down on the
bottom half of the dough leaving about a
half inch of space around the edges once
you have the butter in the correct spot
carefully peel back the parchment paper
to release the butter now fold the top
half of the dough over the butter
stretching it ever so gently so that the
edges of the dough reaches the exposed
edges beneath the butter use the palm of
your hand to gently press the side and
bottom edges of the dough together to
seal the packet closed look at this our
dough looks sort of like a closed book
so moving forward we'll call this the
spine side and this will be the page
side we want to make sure that the
butter rolls out evenly so we'll use our
rolling pin to firmly press the dough
and begin distributing the butter to
release that tension from folding the
dough onto itself we'll use a serrated
knife to cut down the middle of the
spine now make sure to orient the dough
so that the split spine is closest to
you and begin rolling continue rolling
until the dough is about 12 inches high
fluffing and moving the dough to make
sure it doesn't stick to our work
surface once we have the height we want
to roll the dough until it's about a
quarter inch thick it's time to make our
first fold
fold the bottom third of the dough up
and the top third of the dough down kind
of like folding a letter hence why we
call this fold a letter fold we want to
continue rolling out to about the same
size rectangle we had before with a
quarter inch thickness if your rectangle
gets a little wild and has some rounded
edges you can use a serrated knife or a
pastry wheel to straighten out the sides
we want to keep as close to a perfect
rectangle as possible for optimal layers
now we're ready for our second and final
fold
fold the left two thirds of dough over
itself to just past the center of the
dough then fold the right third of the
dough over itself towards the left so
that the edges meet gently press the two
ends together to make a seam that
resembles an offset book spine then fold
the left side of the dough over to meet
the right edge of the dough this is
called a four fold a lot of recipes will
have you resting and folding the dough
three and four times to create a crazy
amount of layers and show off that
iconic honeycomb structure however we
found that although fewer folds creates
fewer layers they're more distinct
layers and honestly give the croissant
our favorite crumb texture light with
just enough chew plus it's a little less
labor intensive our croissants are
really shaping up
but actually let's get to shaping these
babies now we gotta roll the dough out
one more time and you guessed it get
back down to that quarter inch thickness
for this next part we like to use a
pastry wheel but you can also totally
use a large chef's knife begin by
marking three inches and roll the wheel
from the mark diagonally towards the
bottom left corner continue cutting the
rest of the dough until you have about
10 to 12 triangles make a slit in the
middle of the base of each triangle to
help relieve some tension and then roll
them up to create that iconic crescent
shape make sure to roll as tight as
possible without applying too much
pressure so that the croissants will
hold its shape as it proofs and bakes
the french word croissant actually
translates to crescent in english many
historical experts believe french
croissants evolved from austrian kipral
a buttery and often sweet baked good
shaped like a crescent moon according to
the popular legend kipferl dates back to
1683 when a baker heard the ottoman
turks tunneling beneath vienna to lay
siege to it he sounded the alarm to save
the city and created kit frog to
celebrate this victory its curved shape
supposedly symbolized the crescent moon
emblem on the ottoman flag kipral
eventually migrated to france and
evolved into what we now know and love
as the croissant before we get to baking
we have to proof our pastries we like to
add boiling water to a small vessel like
a ramekin and place it on the tray under
the plastic wrap while the croissant's
proof moisture is key to prevent the
dough from drying out you'll know
they're ready to bake when they look
like light puffy clouds they should
slightly wobble when you shake the tray
lastly we'll brush them with an egg wash
to give our croissants that iconic shiny
copper brown shell
and finally it's time to bake
we recommend placing a pan filled with
boiling water at the bottom of your oven
steam ultimately helps the dough grow
before the heat traps it in its shell
bake the croissants in the oven at 350
degrees for about 30 minutes and before
we bite into these works of perfection
we want to let them cool for about 20
minutes and voila perfectly golden
croissants we think croissants taste
best when baked fresh with a smear of
jam or a drizzle of honey and served
with your favorite breakfast beverage
the possibilities are really endless
when it comes to using this laminated
dough to make other beautiful flaky
pastries this recipe is truly a labor of
love and once you nail it the reward is
insanely sweet for this recipe and even
more croissant baking tips check out
tasty.co
croissants really make the world a
butter place
[Music]
you